the guard did it they made it into the
valrant partner program and the words on
everyone's lips
it's about damn time
Gamers I am stage managing a musical and
had to fill in for an entire rehearsal
of an action sequence yesterday so if
you notice any like bumps or bruises I
am totally fine but if you want me to
feel better faster hit that like button
that subscribe button and ring that
notification Bell because a [__] is
hurting so our boys from the guard have
finally done it after a three to one
Clinic against M80 they are finally part
of the same league as NRG Cloud9 and EG
the VCT America's league but in order to
understand just how big of a deal this
is we have to go all the way back to
early 2022 and follow a bit of a long
tail please follow along I promise it
will be worth it in the early days the
VCT there was only one tier for each
region and everyone could qualify for it
no partner teams just grinding through
open qualifiers and that is exactly what
the guard did for the BCT 2022 stage one
Challengers the guard grinded their way
through open qualifiers and qualified in
the most guard way possible look at a
clutches but the spike is down Cosmic
divided under other side he's trying to
hold back towards the sidewalk and lean
out for the first
[__] pancakes and it's gonna be the
guard of winning this 13 to seven that
was the ocean moment for the scene the
scene watching this young Talent Trend
pull off against a crew with some of the
older people in the scene had not been
able to pull off for years this team was
now in the ranks of the old Optics
Sentinels Hunter thieves and Cloud9 if
you had been paying attention to their
nerd Street Run well now they certainly
had your attention in the group stage
they ended up second in group b behind
Cloud9 and in the main event they
defeated optic to become the North
American Champions this meant they
qualified as the first seed from North
America for the next International
Tournament Masters Reykjavik and there
is where things began to go south they
didn't win a single match in Reykjavik
and the only one one map out of the five
they played but by becoming those North
American champions in stage one they
qualified for stage two for stage two
out of the five matches they played they
won one against TSM and yes that stage
two run is where that clip comes from
you
no shot
oh no when he holds it in the smoke I
cannot believe it I have purposely
avoided talking about that clip for over
a year I will never live that clip down
but that is the best representation of
their run good moments but not enough to
overcome their opponents they didn't
qualify for Masters Copenhagen but there
was the last chance qualifier and they
fought tooth and nail to make it to the
Grand finals of the lcq to qualify for
Champions the biggest International
Tournament of the year the only thing
between them and champions hundred
thieves a team they had infamously 13-0
at one point flashed up fully blind
after the other world finds it is
a shot the rifle in his hands it comes
down to this
they were then promptly 3-0 by 100
thieves at this point with them not
qualifying for Champions it was the end
of their season and going into next year
there were even more question marks see
in the background lurking were the
announced changes coming to the VCT no
more open qualifiers but a long-term
partnership model with a select number
of teams in each league teams began to
very clearly throw their hat into the
ring including the guard who literally
lit Sofi stadium with their logo and
valerians but it wasn't enough the guard
was not selected to be a part of the
America's League there were still The
Challengers League where the guard could
compete they could either be selected or
grind their way once again through the
open qualifiers before that could happen
the entire roster announced their
restricted free agency Zia player the
jet with an unconventional playing
posture would be moving to Korea to
compete with T1 and their coach MCE
would leave to join Cloud9 both were
partner teams in their respective
regions Jonah P said to me last year
when the franchising was announced and
everyone was posting their restricted
free agent posts every single one of us
had tryouts and offers from teams in the
league I won't say which teams out of
respect to them in my team but it was a
hard time we didn't know what our
futures were going to look like we
didn't know for a bit if the guard
wanted to stay or not since they missed
the approval from Riot so all that was
left was Jonah P Trent Valen and net
what happens now
well as the saying goes if it ain't
broke don't fix it or in the words of
jonape we had a serious Talk Amongst the
team org and when we found out that the
guard was here to stay and play a round
of Challengers that was the spark we
needed as players to really think about
putting these franchise offers behind us
and continue the Brotherhood we've
created since the beginning with SCI
player and MCE on January 7th 2023 the
guard was announced as a selected team
for North American Challengers the
league set up to allow teams to play
their way into the partnered league on
January 9th the guards roster was
officially announced joining the core 4
would be Tex and they would now be
coached by Josh RT I talked to Valen and
he said we chose this path because we
felt we had something special a team of
five stars with no ego friends in and
out of the game a great group of guys to
work with that commit so much time and
effort into winning and when we lose we
never blame each other the challengers
teams would all fight within their
region to make it to the larger
Ascension tournament where only one team
could make it to the tier one league if
you lost it was back to the beginning
and if you you lose that could mean
losing your job you've already seen this
happen with DSG being relegated from
Challengers and all Talent being let go
everyone knew this was a very real
possibility if your team couldn't hack
it and when things got underway the
guards run was good they won the Ludwig
vitaric Invitational they were making a
good run in their first split
when literally the unthinkable happened
on Wednesday an apparel designer for the
guard tweeted out that quote everyone's
position at the guard has been
eliminated Esports and streaming
reporter Hunter specified that the
layoffs had solely affected the guards
content social talent and creative teams
that happened in the middle of their
first split it took the Esports
Community to its core I cannot imagine
how the team felt but they kept on
playing and they played well fast
forward to June they qualify for the
Ascension tournament the tournament that
could lift them to the very League that
they were denied from a year ago their
biggest competition fellow n a darling
and new kid on the Block M80 the guard
were finally back at an international
competition and as a reminder Reykjavik
All Things Considered went terribly
would they choke on an international
stage again could they handle the
pressure and bring themselves to be a
part of the league where so many thought
they belonged it is July 9th 2023
450 days since they first stepped onto
an International stage and as the
scriptwriters would have it the only
thing standing in between them and tier
one is M80 time to come and get a shoot
shock Dart set out preemptively no one
home start gets placed
it's a nebula EU tries to hang on to it
but no it's Trent to find the final kill
but in 471 days since the rookies made
it to Reykjavik but today is the day
where veterans qualify for VCT the one
who fired the final bullet to bring them
to the 2022 Challenger stage where so
many had met them for the first time
once again fires the final bullet to
bring them to the Tier 1 America's
League the guard months and months after
loss and victory grinding and heartbreak
have finally done it they want Ascension
and are in I want you to watch this I
want you to watch the smiles on their
faces net jumping with excitement this
team has been put through the ringer
they were forced to prove themselves all
over again in the most grueling format
possible and they did it the young igl
the most underrated Flex player in North
America the impressive and grounded
Sentinel the inhuman duelist everyone's
favorite initiator and the coach that
guided them through it all and Maya the
often forgotten general manager that was
there for them literally since the
beginning Jonah Pugh said we knew we
deserved to be enfranchised we've been
at the top before we've beaten all of
these teams many times before so we knew
we could do it the hard way and grind
through Challengers and that's what we
did we put our everything into this
league with just under 600 scrims this
year and the same amount of time or even
more put into VOD review we were ready
for this and we are ready to be where we
were meant to be in VCT Americas I
hesitate to call the team resilience
because I don't think that word does
them Justice the team is filled with
young men with Incredible maturity grit
Grace and growth they are a home where
they have always belonged in the VCT
America's league and to the other teams
in the league let this be your ocean
moment like the one you had back in 2022
when you watched Trent put the final
nail on the coffin of a crew because
they are back
and they are coming for you
stage managing is lots of fun being in
charge of making the environment for
these kids as safe as possible so they
can explore learn play make mistakes in
the theater I know how much that meant
to me growing up it's been an awesome
summer so far and I'm I'm it's just
really really awesome
um I am very very sore though like I I
took an animal this morning like I'm in
so much pain